I don't care it is famously Donald
Trump's favorite pastime
but just a few miles from his front door
opinions on the fairways are fiercely
divided on his indictment what does it
make you think that a former president
is charged with a crime I love it I want
to see him handcuffed I want to see him
in an orange suit
I think he deserves everything he gets
Sue and her girlfriends remember a time
when Trump running for president was
treated as a joke here almost a decade
on he's in the dock
crook he's a thief we knew that before
he ever got in office
but people voted him in and he still has
followers and I would say that even if
he ran for president there's a good
chance he could still get in
plenty of people here would still vote
for Donald Trump in 2024 if he gets the
Republican nomination
Clubhouse manager and snack bar
attendant Tony the Tiger Lopez came to
the U.S from Mexico 43 years ago Donald
Trump became the best president ever in
in ever in United States and it is
embarrassing for America to do the
canister to our president so the fact
that he's being charged with a serious
crime doesn't affect the way you think
about him I believe is political
I may not vote for Donald Trump long
voted for Trump in 2020 but might look
elsewhere next time but still he thinks
the criminal charges against him are
politically motivated they're just
walking to put some put some incidents
out there
and if they stick fine if they don't
they haven't they don't have anything to
lose
because they're not their names aren't
being dragged through the mud
even as his fingerprints are being taken
Trump is collecting millions of dollars
in donations from his loyal base
polls show he is still the driving force
in the Republican party I have friends
that I mean nafik the Herman video
shooting somebody and killing somebody
they would still support them the round
of golf continues so too does the drama
Division and debate which as ever
surrounds Donald Trump Martha Kellner
Sky News Florida